hey guys Pete here it's happening again
Twin Peaks finally made it back to TV
this will be my review and recap of
parts 1 and 2 of the return which is
technically two episodes in the
beginning of season 3 but really it's
just one big long episode so if you
haven't watched yet this will contain a
ton of spoilers and will basically ruin
it so if you haven't watched it go watch
it now and then come back well I do my
recap and review as I go through the
entire thing what happened who we met
all that stuff and then at the end we
talked about possible theories and
things that are going on and going
through our minds at the end I will put
a timestamp link in the bottom if you
don't want to recap you just want to
talk about what's happening and that
will skip you to the end so at long last
it did debut and it was awesome I have
to say I mean I don't have any problems
with any of it I think I'll get into a
lot more of that later but I think both
diehard fans and newbies will enjoy this
new season so it starts out with old
footage first we get a glimpse back to
the waiting room or the Red Room and we
see Laura tell Cooper that she'll see
him again in 25 years this is all before
the opening credits which is a new
opening credits scene still has the same
awesome song but it has a different look
now we don't have the little bird that's
sitting there and all that kind of stuff
our first new scene is the giant who was
an original character and Cooper who we
assume is the good Cooper that's in the
lodge and they're in a new room and I
don't know if this is White Lodge or if
this is just some other place we haven't
learned about yet he has a phonograph
player there the giant doesn't he tells
Cooper to listen to the sounds we can't
tell what they are and he says that they
are in their house now he says remember
4:30 Richard and Linda and then he says
two birds one stone which I didn't
understand but coop tells us that he
understands Jayden says you are far away
and Cooper disappears from the room we
see another old character we know dr.
Jacoby who now lives in a camper out
the woods which it doesn't tell us at
the bottom where it is but we do see
Douglas fir so we should assume based on
what we know from the secret history
that he's still in the Twin Peaks area
he's getting a delivery of shovels and
no idea what that's all about but the
guy who's delivering massaman if he
wants any help and dr. Jacoby says he
likes to work alone then we go to New
York City which is brand new territory
for Twin Peaks we meet a new character
and we see this crazy yet unexplained
setup with a chamber made of glass it
has a hole like porthole to the outside
and it's sealed with cameras all around
it the guy who's watching it seemed
super straight-laced and meticulous and
we see that there's tight security we
meet another new character named Tracy
she's female and she is bringing coffee
for the guy who is watching the box
neither one of them seems to be from
that area they're both students it seems
like from in the Midwest somewhere based
on their accents and the way they talk
she asked to get inside he won't let her
in saying that it's top secret then we
get a shot of the Great Northern and we
find out Ben Horne is still there he's
still in charge he has this awesome
wouldn't nameplate on his desk and we
also see his brother Jerry who is now a
stoner who has formed a new business
growing weed for the horns we also meet
Ashley Judd who is his new assistant or
new secretary but we don't find anything
else out about her except for Ben says
he's not sleeping with her and that
she's married over at the Twin Peaks
Sheriff's Department we see that Lucy
has not changed much at all when this
insurance man comes in he asks to see
the sheriff and she asks which one we
find out two important things here I
would guess one that one of the sheriff
truman's is sick
that would be harry s truman and that
his older brother is out fishing that's
Frank Truman she doesn't tell us this
directly but we can infer it from what
we know we didn't get this crate creepy
little driving scene in the back woods
or wherever we can't really tell where
it's at and we see this slick Mercedes
and then oh my god
Cooper gets out and it's clearly the
evil Cooper who has a brand new look and
immediately we see him kick some ass we
meet a guy named Otis a woman named
viola and he tells her that he needs Rey
and aria and takes them along with him
there's a little there's a little thing
here where they both look like they give
a index card to this little guy that's
sitting in a wheelchair in the back of
the room I'm not sure if that's
important or not but it was kind of
weird the security guard is missing when
Tracy comes this time and that lets her
get inside the room the guy explains he
doesn't understand what the glass box is
for and things escalate to where they
start to have sex and they find out
briefly what the box is going on with it
before a shadow figure comes out and
basically kills them by biting them in
the face that's the best I could tell I
think it was literally they were bitten
in the face to death then we go to our
next destination which is Buckhorn South
Dakota the police there come to
investigate a strange smell it's a funny
scene and it's some new characters there
but none of them seem very important
except maybe max pearl edge who plays a
character who seems to be up to
something the cops obviously find a dead
body or possibly bodies because it looks
like the head is of a female and the
body is a male from there we go to and
we see at the log lady one of my
favorite characters and we're really
awesome to see her back and she calls
deputy or should I say chief deputy hawk
on the phone saying that her log has a
message for him
she says the log tells him that
something is missing and you have to
find it it has something to do with
Special Agent Dale Cooper the way you
will find it it has something to do with
your heritage this is a message from the
law huh doesn't look to put out by the
whole scenario like maybe she calls him
from time to time and he just sits there
and thinks back in buck when we find out
the head is ruth's the person whose
apartment they were it was found in but
the body is a male John Doe and the
police have found a ton of prints from
someone named William Hastings inside
and all over the apartment mr. hasting
gets arrested
we'll find out more about him later back
at the station we see that Hawk has
pulled out some boxes we see Andy for
the first time and we find out that
Cooper has been missing since before
lolly was born well is there son we
imagine and Bali is now 20 feet four
years old which means that no one has
seen Agent Dale Cooper said in the
season two Pok tells them not to worry
about how long it's been since they've
seen Cooper but in the morning they're
going to look for some files he tells
them to get everything ready and he'll
bring the coffee and donuts in South
Dakota the police searched Bill's house
and they find what looks like a finger
in the trunk in the process of that we
find out that him and his wife pretty
much hate each other and that he was
having affair with Ruth he swears to his
wife though that he wasn't there but he
had a dream that night sounds a little
suspicious but we don't find out
anything more about it at that moment he
tells her that he knows that she's
having affair with his lawyer and we
find out that she's pretty much glad
that he's going to prison for life after
she leaves we see a dark character in a
cell nearby that disappears or does
something supernatural and goes away at
the end of the scene when she gets home
she finds coop in her house the evil
coupe obviously and he kills her with
the lawyers gun now it seems that she
knew him so he was behind everything
that happened there but he then leaves
and the wound looks kind of strange but
I don't know if there's anything to that
or not we had to Las Vegas and we meet
mr. Todd who hands his assistant or
someone who works for him named Roger
some cab he says tell her she has the
job Roger asked why mr. Todd lets him
make him do things like that and mr.
Todd says that he hopes that Roger will
never know what it's like to have
someone like him in his life so we find
out that mr. Todd is in business with
someone that he doesn't want to be in
business with we see a railroad crossing
in a diner and we find coop inside with
ray and daria ray has access to
information through a contact we learn
is Hastings secretary Cooper makes it
very clear that he doesn't need anything
that he wants things and
this information is something that he
wants he also tells him that he's gonna
be heading out on his own soon and he
better be able to trust that information
is good
there's no location title here to say
where this is in the beginning of the
episode I thought that might mean that
the scenes that weren't marked were in
the Twin Peaks area but this kind of
throws that out of the kind of throws it
out of whack at this point so I'm not
sure where he is somewhere between South
Dakota and somewhere else perhaps we
catch up with Hawk again while he's
walking through the woods and the log
lady calls him on the phone we
immediately realize where he's going
when he says when she says the star
turns and a time presents itself sure
enough he's where agent Cooper entered
the lodge and we get a look inside the
good agent Cooper and Mike are sitting
inside the Red Room and Mike says is it
future or is it past someone is here
then Mike disappears and Laura walks
into the room she's aged 25 years as is
Cooper for the for what it's worth and
at first she tells him he can go out now
then ask if he recognizes her Cooper
asks if she's Laura Palmer and she says
she feels like she knows her but
sometimes her arms bent back yes who she
is and she answers Laura Palmer to what
she says while Laura Palmer's dead and
she says I am dead and yet I'd live then
she removes her face more or less and we
see that she's basically made of light
like there's light blowing out of the
inside of her being he asked when he can
go and then she approaches him she gives
him a kiss and then whispers in his ear
like his dream from the original series
he seemed startled by what he hears and
then she starts screaming I don't know
exactly how to describe what happens
next but basically while she's screaming
she flies up into the sky or towards the
ceiling and disappears wind starts
blowing around inside then we see the
curtains moving we see the white horse
before it turns black and then Mike
returns to ask the same question again
Mike then takes
Cooper outside of the room and we learn
how they solved the Michael J Anderson
problem remember Michael J Anderson was
the
from another place who we knew wasn't
coming back or this season the arm or
the man from the other place has evolved
into a tree of sorts yes coop if he
remembers his doppelganger the tree
asked coop that and we see more old
footage where we're reminded how that
all went down at the end of season two
and perhaps some of that stuff is from
fire walk with me as well the arm tells
Cooper that his doppelganger has to come
back in before he can go out back
outside we see evil coop stashing his
Mercedes and getting into what looks
like law enforcement or FBI kind of car
the guy Jack we met earlier is hiding it
for him and before he leaves he grabs
Jack's face and rubs it until it almost
looks like he's frozen in time they're
evil Cooper arrives back at a hotel room
where Daria is talking on the phone she
lies and says she was talking to Jack
but we gathered that she's probably
talking to Ray evil couplets or no that
he was recording the conversation and
eventually kills her but before that we
find out ray got popped and that he had
spoken to the secretary we also learned
that someone wanted to have Cooper
killed and she was supposed to do it and
that Cooper was supposed to return to
the lodge but he has a plan on how to
get out of that after he kills Darya he
pulls out a case that looks really
similar to what Windham Aurel was
carrying around in season two he talks
to someone that he thinks is Philip
Jeffries the person doesn't confirm who
it is but says that Cooper's going back
into the lodge tomorrow and that he will
be with Bob again Cooper then gets on an
odd-looking computer in the box it looks
like it's connected to the FBI but it's
sort of all flickering and I'm not
really sure what's going on with that
either way he downloads all the info
about the prison and then goes next door
where we meet Jennifer Jason Leigh's
character Chantel he tells her he needs
her to go clean up next door where he
murdered Aria and then she has to go get
her boyfriend because he needs her and
Hutch in a particular place in a couple
of days back inside the lodge the arm
says two five three time and time again
then repeats Bob Bob Bob at the end of
that he says go now and we see Mike and
Cooper leave that room the sequence that
follows is mysterious and hard to follow
but basically what we see is agent
Cooper moving through the rooms he runs
into Leland at one point who says find
Laura and then we see Mike and the arm
again and Mike says that something's
wrong the arm says it's his doppelganger
and we see that not only Cooper has a
doppelganger the arms doppelganger
appears and then sends Cooper out of the
lodge after he gives him a glimpse of
evil coupe driving down a highway
agent Cooper passes through the glass
box where we see those characters
briefly but it doesn't seem like they
see him it seems like they were outside
the room when he passes through it's
impossible to tell exactly what's going
on here but it seems like we can gather
that agent Cooper is back and is no
longer in the lodge nause in New York we
don't know is he just passing through
there no idea after that we get a couple
more looks at the town of Twin Peaks we
see Laura Palmer at home and the old
Palmer House drinking and watching a
pack of lions overtaking the water
buffalo
then we go back to the Roadhouse where
we see Shelley out with some friends
James comes in with another new
character with the British accent and we
find out that he had a motorcycle
accident and that he's more quiet now
Shelley says he's still cool though just
like he has always been cool we find out
that Shelley has a daughter named Becky
but nothing more about that and we also
see what looks like jock renault working
behind the bar it is the same actor you
can find out in the credits but now it
says that he's listed as John Michelle
Renault so we don't know anything more
about that right underneath that - we
can see that Al stroll Strobel who is
the actor who plays Mike is actually the
person that the evil coupe was talking
to not Phillip Jess or what says he is
Phillip Jeffries or played Phillip
Jeffries so it's not conclusive one way
or the other but it does say that that
was Mike's voice that we heard through
the machine so mystery with a side of
mystery lots of black large stuff to
think about plus a big
to the frosting inside of things with
the final scene at the Roadhouse I can't
lie I loved it I pretty much loved all
of it and yeah
loved it it was Twin Peaks it was
different and yet it was the same just
like Laura's dead yet she lives now I
haven't thought too deeply about things
yet or read anything else but my initial
reaction is that we're going to be in
for a wild ride for the next 16 episodes
I wasn't expecting last but you know
it's kind of hard to figure out
resurrection they were gonna go in and I
think they captured enough of what we
already knew and just went into a
direction that's working right now if
the good Cooper's been missing for the
past 25 years until this new celestial
event which opened the lodge again where
does the scene with the giant fit in
with that that's the thing that's kind
of bugging me the most right now is that
we have that as the opening scene and
real in present time or whatever but it
could really happen anytime in between
season 2 and season 3 in present time or
at least the you know the main timeline
of the show it's clear that he has a
dilemma
the evil coupe is supposed to be
returning to the lodge but he has no
intention of doing so but the arms
doppelganger has a plan as well which
seems to be contrary to Mike and the
arms plan and let's just go ahead and
mention that right now who's good and
who's bad there is there good and bad
there I mean in Cooper's case we know
that there was the normal Cooper who was
essentially good and that he has a
doppelganger that is essentially not
good but the man from another place is
like a totally different story and
there's Mike outside Philip Michael
Gerard and then there's Mike inside and
it's not really clear whose side anybody
is on inside there with that in mind
here are the big questions that I'm
thinking about other than that whole
thing with the giant first and foremost
how did Cooper originally dispute
disappear from Twin Peaks based on what
we heard from Andy and Lucy it seems
like it's been so long that it you know
basically everyone's just accepts it
it's faded to memory for the most part
what's going on with Laura she wants
somewhere but where Leland
seems to think that she needs to be
found but is he aware of what Cooper
just saw
I mean basically Leland could have just
been sitting in that chair for the last
25 years for all we know and that brings
up a big point does anything actually
happen in the waiting room as far as
time is concerned or all these
characters somewhere else and then they
just all came back together there
because of what's going on with the
planets what the hell does Jacoby need
so many shovels I mean that scene was in
there for a reason but it you know we
didn't really get much of more
information about it at all now the
giant and the arm both mentioned numbers
number 4 3 0 & 2 5 3 they sound like
times but why that why would they be
important as times and is this something
that we're supposed to be able to piece
together or just random things to add to
the mystery gine also mention Richard
and Linda but the arm only mentioned Bob
so names numbers I don't know if they're
supposed to be some kind of you know in
and yang going on there or not we saw a
Rick you know several of the original
characters but we know from you know the
cast lists and everything that a lot
more haven't shown up yet I think they
did a pretty good job with the ones they
aren't able to you know still have in
the show like Phillip Jeffries and the
man from another place now just being
the evolution of the arm
based on the final scene I feel like we
will definitely be getting plenty of
soap opera kind of stuff you know in the
future episodes I don't think people who
missed that are gonna be left out this
one was somewhat dark but it was really
more of just filling in kind of key
elements that we need to go to move
forward the glass box in the South
Dakota storylines are completely
mysterious for the most part I mean
obviously evil coupe / Bob is tied to
the South Dakota storyline but is that
that character that we saw the black
character and the jail is that supposed
to literally beat Bob I mean there's no
way to know at least the figure that
killed the people in the New York scene
seems to be something brand-new but why
don't you guys tell me what you think in
the comments because there's just a lot
to speculate and all of that so like I
said I really enjoyed it I'm looking
forward to watching episodes 3 and 4 as
soon as I
finish editing this one if this is long
I know but it was a longer episode so in
the future these won't be so far dragged
out make sure you subscribe to my
channel and check back because I'll be
doing a bunch of different stuff
throughout this Twin Peaks season I've
been working on a secret history video
that should be coming out between
episodes at some point after I read that
mark frost announced that the final book
is gonna be coming out after this season
I realized that that's probably a lot
more important so I've been going back
through it and finding some interesting
stuff to share with you guys about that
also if you have questions please leave
them in the comments I may do a Q&A if
there is enough interest and I will be
researching and reading and looking at
everything getting my hands on in
between now and the time a new episode
air so there'll probably be another
video related to this in one way or
another but for now it's time to move on
so thanks for watching I'll talk to you
soon